here's a really interesting question
if i ask you as a probably you know the
the who's the typical david pakman show
viewer just on average the david pakman
show viewer is
a college educated
often making more than 75 000 a year
mostly male as many of these shows are
vaccinated
individual okay the average david pakman
show viewer and of course there's people
of all kinds in the audience i'm just
giving you the demographic data we have
about how our audience skews the average
david pakman show viewer if you ask them
if i ask them i'll ask you right now
who is to blame
for the accelerated rise in covid that
we are seeing right now what what
individuals
most of you would say the people who
have chosen not to get vaccinated now of
course the delta variant is more
contagious we're still understanding
seasonality decreased waning efficacy of
the vaccine after the eight-month period
all these different things but obviously
if everybody was vaccinated by now we
wouldn't be seeing what we are seeing
right now in particular hospitalizations
and deaths now let me ask you a
different question
if i asked you
what or who would the average
unvaccinated person blame
for the spike in kovid what would you
say
well there is a new
axios uh ipsos poll
and it is absolutely insane look at this
so i'm putting the graph up on the
screen i'm gonna explain it to everybody
okay the answers in green are the
answers of
vaccinated people whereas the answers in
red are the answers of unvaccinated
people so case in point you go to the
vaccinated and you say what's to blame
for the rise of covid and the new
variants 79
of the vaccinated say the unvaccinated
are to blame okay that's that's backed
up by science uh the vaccinated also
blame in descending order donald trump
uh conservative media now they're not
saying trump is infecting people but
it's the vaccine hesitant and covet
isn't serious rhetoric of trump
conservative media doing the same thing
foreign travelers in the u.s americans
traveling internationally etc okay
the unvaccinated
they immediately gravitate to foreign
travelers in the u.s are the ones that
are to blame
and then they go to mainstream media
is to blame
and in fourth place they have joe biden
is to blame
and then they have the cdc is to blame
and then they have national public
health officials are to blame this is a
completely backwards view
the and by the way
only 9.8
of the unvaccinated
blame themselves
for what is going on right now this is a
view which is based on
why why do we blame the cdc
and the national public health officials
well because they can't be trusted and
fauci was wrong about masks in march of
2020 and they're spreading lies and gain
of function research and all of this
different stuff joe biden is to blame
joe biden has been trying to get people
vaccinated biden's to blame what what
are you talking about
um and then foreign travelers in the
united states seems to be the point of
agreement
right around you know 29 uh i'll put the
numbers back up on the board 29
of the vaccinated and 37 percent of the
unvaccinated say foreign travelers in
the u.s are to blame that's the one
where these numbers are
relatively close this is just a world
view that is totally disconnected from
what the science tells us so how do we
deal with this
these are not folks listen if you think
mainstream media is behind the explosion
of delta case infections
and hospitalizations and deaths
how are we going to be able to have an
even remotely substantive conversation
with you we're not going to be able to
so then what do we have to do
we probably have to do what some cities
and states or mostly cities are starting
to do you want to go to the movies you
got to be vaccinated
you want to go to a restaurant and sit
indoors you got to be vaccinated i'll
talk on the bonus show today about my my
trip
when i was in germany
i went to a place that had like an out
it was like a beer garden german beer
garden had a big outdoor area and an
indoor area i went to the door
the waitress comes up and says if you
want to go inside i need to see
vaccination or a negative test from
today
um and it makes sense that that's what
you would start doing you've got to
start making it more annoying
not to be vaccinated because if you
think mainstream media is behind the
ryzen cases and not the fact that we've
only fully vaccinated roughly half the
country
then it's going to be very hard to
convince you otherwise really really
difficult stuff and by the way speaking
of can't you just fake a vaccine card
yeah
you can and that's actually the topic of
today's voicemail